oh
there's so many moving parts to it that
you have to get approval from so many
people especially on star wars
oh
yeah she's in pain how do you jump out
of a moving car without hurting yourself
this video is brought to you by
expressvpn stick around to the end to
see how you can get three months for
free
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of stuntman
woman react we are here with lauren mary
kim she's joining us once again you
might remember her from another episode
we did we talked about the mandalorian
we talked about motion capture for the
clone wars and we're here to look at
some more really cool stunts not to
mention you were in the mandalorian
season too weren't you yes i was
definitely a couple girls yeah we have a
lot of really cool clips to look at
today so let's jump in let's do it
oh
jumping into mando this is a good
episode yeah
i like the lightsabers actually give off
light it's a very nice touch
that's all you in the wide right here
right yeah wides definitely are yeah but
diana is amazing she's a real martial
artist her dad is my guru they like
casting women that are actually really
good at actually this is hard like gina
carrano like sasha banks so they like
getting legit girls that can really
throw down which is really cool they're
representing like life and like real
people and like real fighters
[Music]
oh nice what's that move called again
webster yeah he had to pick between two
lightsabers one lightsaber or darth
maul's double-sided lightsaber which one
would you pick double saber for sure
like musashi style yeah how do you fight
with two weapons fighting with one sword
you're either defending and attacking or
attacking defending but when you have
two yeah you can do multiple things you
could attack and defend at the same time
you can double strike at someone you can
go from low to high at the same time
it's kind of endless
it's so funny because i've only seen
this fight like maybe two times so now
to watch it it's like really cool to
actually see it
again
i actually posted a rehearsal footage of
me and caitlyn doing it in a parking lot
yeah how long does it take you to
rehearse a scene like that we were able
to get a couple weeks on it ryan watson
did such a good job choreographing it
he's our stunt coordinator they would
photograph the scene and of course it
changed like a billion times before it
got to where it is today yeah i mean
there's so many moving parts to it that
you have to get approval from so many
people especially on star wars now when
you guys are doing this does the stunt
coordinator come to you and say i got it
here it is or is it like let's figure
this out together it's usually a team
effort because it's hard sometimes decor
got both sides we would have some input
as well like what we thought would be
cool it's always a group effort were
there any unforeseen challenges in this
scene actually no it was like a dream
actually to like work on this scene
everyone's so easy to work with too like
rosario's awesome she's the nicest
person and i worked with her on
defenders and daredevil it's so cool to
see her transition into star wars
[Music]
[Applause]
what are they using for the lightsabers
is it just led tubes or like is the kind
of lightsaber you get at like disneyland
well the hilts were legit and i think
what we see is pretty much what it was
there was lighting in it yeah because we
had to like emulate the lights on her
face yeah since you guys are using
actual light up props for the
lightsabers i assume they couldn't take
a huge beating you had to be a little
careful with them like yeah were you
guys pulling your hits to try a little
bit like yeah
yeah but like with all stunt fights you
don't like hit hard to like really
annihilate the person yeah you have to
still do your move so yeah there's
definitely some finesse into that have
you ever been
popped by an actor who was trying to get
in and do their little stunts yes i got
punched in the face by dan blizzarian
really yeah that guy yes punched me in
the face and didn't even say sorry he
had to do like you know like a cross
hook or something and he literally
crossed me in my eye jeez yeah so that
was gnarly the point is you want to be
in control at all times right right and
no distance don't actually come out at
their face sometimes you just gotta
educate people
but then sometimes i get messages from
like fans and they're like oh i just did
this fall for you and i want to show you
how i did it and i was like no no don't
really do it we have pads on we have
like mats sometimes you look at the
footage and it's just like this kid just
yeah
like on the knee the back breaker
this is for you
on concrete
i said this before the show but i feel
like there's a common misconception that
the job of a stunt man or something
woman is to go on set and get hurt so
the actor doesn't get hurt when the job
of the stuntman or sudden person is to
go on set and make it look like they're
getting hurt without getting hurt
exactly exactly but there's the risk of
getting hurt of course yeah then there's
like stunts that are legitly hard like
car hits
that's my target wow yeah that one
sucked but the cool thing is i don't
really remember it so
i wonder why
like it just happened it was done and i
was like oh we're done already yeah
it was a one and done situation oh yeah
because i landed on my neck
oh yeah
that was that was two cameras like two
angles three yeah we did in one let's
look at this car here
no one knows this michael's actually an
accredited stunt performer i'm a stunt
action person the rocker rocket guys are
professional stunt men they're awesome
action cinematographers but they also do
stunts out in australia both on film and
for their own stuff
oh my god yo
that makes you think because i've seen
that stunt actually happen on set a lot
where they just fall on a car yeah and
he's bouncing off so i guess the force
of it would make you bounce off but on
tv they always make you like just hit it
and that's it i mean are they wearing
pads oh he's got a back pad on you can
see it there oh yeah yeah thank god
oh he got the toe he got the toe in oh
he did the guitar yeah
why go for the toe what's the toe move
here basically anytime you're falling
you hit your foot first and then it
helps impact the fall so it's a less
gnarly hit but you get more kudos if you
don't do that
their harry potter fight is like the
funniest
what separates it from like fan film is
that they're destroying their house oh
my god just annihilating everything dude
it's all about the broom
this right here
[Laughter]
that's so good that's great
the cinematography is so good for how
rough it looks yeah totally it's not
rough like it's so thought out when the
cuts are happening it all pastes action
together so well you're constantly
surprised like oh that's pretty legit
yeah oh that's cool the way they do that
you know yeah i mean they make a
business out of it i think they're
getting grants from australia to be able
to do this stuff they built a set of
their house so it's not just run and gun
like it feels that way but it's a bit
more produced okay
hey you know the thing that like other
youtube channels do where they say like
this percentage of people watching this
video aren't subscribed well guess what
we started that now everybody's doing it
and everyone else is saying it's super
annoying so i'm just gonna say please
subscribe if you aren't subscribed we
appreciate it and helps out our videos
thank you also i just checked the
numbers 100 of you are subscribed so
there's no point using that anymore
[Music]
i'm johnny knoxville this is the jet ski
what is this
[Music]
have you ever been in a situation where
you had to do something like that and
you just had to go for it knowing that
it's gonna really hurt yeah like i did
the car hit i had to jump out of moving
cars you just know it's going to kind of
suck yeah for sure how do you jump out
of a moving car without hurting yourself
sorry while minimizing
yeah there is actually ways me and
another guy had to jump out together oh
and people actually have died from this
if they toe tap the force of them
hitting their feet first they would hit
the back of the car so the way to do it
is that we had to like come out
horizontal to the ground so that the car
can get away and then you're not hitting
anything just cleanly hitting the ground
horizontally so definitely no toe
tapping in that situation
oh yeah he toe tap and i guess you kind
of had
that situation but oh it smacks the back
of his head on the road yeah
there's no way that he couldn't toe top
that so for this right here is he doing
it twice or is he just going onto a
landing platform and he could be going
into a process that'd be a big process
trailer it would be yeah then james
cameron mentioned that he said they
actually did it twice one where he
cracked his head and he's like we're
like all right we gotta do it again ah
he had to do one more time he didn't
crack his head the second time and then
james cameron uses the one where he hit
his head on the pavement okay wow dude
he didn't bleed i'm sure he did but you
know i mean the thing is is that the
stunt guy or is that the actor or is it
an actor that they cast that's a stunt
person too that's probably it
this is a highly recommended fall in the
comments by the way any cool stunts you
would love us to react to please leave a
comment below because that's how we find
a lot of these really cool clips
oh
crunch
oh my god rocks i think they really did
this obviously because you can't really
fake this this is just takes balls oh
dude that where he like gets picked up
on his shoulders and spins on the top of
his head how do you feel about their
necks when you look at their necks
do you look at that next nap
they're gonna have problems in the
morning yeah dude doing this with a gun
prop slung around you would also be
really tough hopefully it's made of foam
hopefully i would think it it is it
definitely is but you know that's the
actor right there there's some shots of
the actors doing this too well that one
is probably like a calculated one like
yeah so yeah they're setting up for that
one the actor one is definitely gonna be
help lauren is this one of those
situations where you just gotta pad up
and do your best oh yeah definitely have
to pad up for sure you come in with
energy because you don't wanna do it
five million times even though it seems
like they did it five million times
because if you do it half energy and
it's like obviously point yeah like that
oh see that guy came in with energy you
just sold it that's my like mentality
why do it half ass when first of all
everyone's waiting on you you want to
get the shot in as least takes as
possible so just go for it in my mind
i'm always like all right if i just go
for it we maybe only have to do it like
one to three times and we'll get it and
that's just the mentality you have to
have and not think about fear just being
like oh it's gonna be great you know i'm
gonna be really healthy and then that's
it like you just have like a good mental
attitude about it
oh
that's so brutal
oh that was a cool stunt am i right but
you know what's cooler than any stunt
protecting your internet privacy because
our sponsor today is expressvpn one of
the most valuable commodities in this
day and age is our private information
and when you're just randomly surfing
the internet that's out there for a lot
of people to see advertisers internet
service providers all of these people
want your info but when you're using a
vpn that's all encrypted it's like if
you were to take your connection to the
internet and put a force field around it
you are protected and it can fool the
internet into thinking that you live
somewhere else this actually comes with
some really cool advantages for instance
something that's really cool i wanted to
watch the dark knight but it's not
available on netflix here in the states
but if i connect to brazil's server
through expressvpn i can actually start
watching that right now and it's
streaming at like full hd's because
expressvpn has the fastest speeds
they've got the most secure connection
and they have 24 7 support so you can
get help anytime you need it there are
plenty of other countries that have much
better netflix libraries and you should
have access to them too unlock your
potential all you gotta do is go to
expressvpn.com
corridor crew and you will get three
months for free when you sign up guys do
exactly what i did i clicked the link in
that description and i got my three
months for free i didn't have to say
that that's a true story all right now
let's go see some awesome stunts lauren
mary kim is the mandalorian
lauren
thank you so much for taking the time to
come down here and break down some cool
stunts with us it means a lot thank you
oh well thanks for having me again i am
like humbled by you guys and like
honored to be here
we always learn we always learn a lot we
always learn a lot and there's there's
so much to learn so every time you come
down we learn a little bit more and it's
awesome you're the one who actually has
to go out there and take the hits which
ones you just get to talk about
so i mean you guys could do a jackass
scene if you guys want to and do your
own oh my god
then we'll be like adrian
[Applause]
did you break your collarbone yeah i
think i broke my collarbone we don't
want to do that hey so if you guys want
to follow more of lauren's work you can
find her on instagram and youtube under
lauren mary kim so check her out leave
her message say hey
and we'll see you guys next time